you mentioned gato's a completeness
theorem uh can you can you talk a little
bit about it what is it as you
understand it did it break mathematics
maybe another question is what are the
limits of mathematics what is
mathematics from the perspective of
getting us to completeness theorem well
yes
how much time do you have
we talked about time previously so that
was an illusion right so we agreed
was a great uh Austrian mathematician
and logician
he moved to the United States before
second world war and worked at The
Institute for advanced study in
Princeton where he was a colleague of
Einstein and other great scientists for
Neumann Hermann Weil and so on but you
know one one interesting
uh quote that I like disregard is that
Einstein said that at some point he said
that the only reason he came to the
Institute was that he would have the
privilege of walking back home with godo
in the evening so in other words
Einstein thought that the girl was the
smart one okay so
um so he um his most important
contribution
was his two incompleteness ethereums the
first incompleteness theorem and the
second incompleteness theorem
and um
what is this about it's really about
limitation inherent limitations of
mathematical reasoning
but my way of producing mathematical
theorems the way we do it so to set the
stage
how do we actually do mathematics what
is so you know we know that we discussed
that
say physics is based on mathematics and
you could say chemistry is based on
physics biology based on chemistry okay
so it comes to mathematics what is
mathematics based on
well mathematics is based on axioms
so any
field of mathematics is
can be can be presented as what is
called the formal system
and at the core of the formal system you
use a system of axioms or postulas these
are the statements
which are taken for granted given
without proof without proof an example
would be so that one of the very first
formal systems was the system was
euclidean geometry developed by Euclid
in his famous book elements about 2200
years ago
and it's about it's well it's a subject
Familia from from school because we
studied
but what it's really about is about the
geometry of the plane and the plane by
plane I mean just the stable top
extended to Infinity no directions kind
of a perfect plane a perfect perfectly
even table
and um
so euclidean geometry is about very
geometric figures on the plane
specifically lines triangles circles
things like that
so what's an example of an Axion an
example of an axiom is that if you have
two points
which are not which are distinct two
points on the plane then there is a
unique line which passes through them
now kind of sounds reasonable
but this is an example of an Axion
in mathematics you can you have to have
a seed so to speak you have to start
with something
and you have to choose certain
postulates or statements which you
simply take for granted which do not
require proof usually they are ones
which kind of intuitively clear to you
but in any case you cannot have you
could not have any mathematics without
choosing those actions and you refer to
those as the Observer because they're
kind of subjective The Observer comes in
the process of choosing the axons
coach uses the axons the turtles
you know like to say who is watching the
Watchers yeah and so in mathematics but
you see mathematicians are so clever
it's really kind of like a little kind
of a game of mirrors that we often like
to say and I used to say that
um that mathematics is objective it's
really one the only objective science
but that's because we hide this
this fact is based on axioms and the
fact that
that there is no there is no unique
choice
there are many choices
and so euclidean geometry is actually a
good illustration of this because
Euclid had five axioms four of them were
kind of obvious like the one I just
mentioned and the fifth
which came to be known famously as the
fifth postulate was that if you have a
line
and you have a point outside of this
there is a unique line passing through
that point which is parallel to the
first line meaning that doesn't
intersect it
and Euclid himself was uncomfortable
about this because he felt that it was
kind of a you know the York City takes
for granted something that is not
obvious
and for me for many for many centuries
after that mathematicians were trying to
derive this action from other actions
which were more obvious in some sense
and they failed
and it was only almost 2000 years later
that mathematians realized that you
can't not only you cannot derive but you
can actually replace it with its
opposite
and you'll still get a bonafide
a consistent no it's not
self-contradictory which is called
non-euclidean geometry
which of course sounds very complicated
but it's not think of a sphere just the
surface of a basketball or the surface
of the Earth I know idealized
the analogues so do you have points you
have analogues of lines which have
meridians right and every two meridians
intersect
unlike parallel lines on a flat space
there is also so-called hyperbolic plane
where
no the infinitely many lines which do
not intersect so every possibility can
be realized there are different flavors
this is a good illustration of what a
formal system is
you start with a set of axioms
those statements you take for granted
and this is where you have a choice and
by making different choices you actually
create different mathematics
after that there are rules of inference
logical rules such as if a is true and a
implies B then B is true
most of them were actually introduced
already by Aristotle
even before Euclid
and then it runs as follows
you have the axioms which are accepted
as true statements then you have a way
to produce new statements
by using the rules of logical inference
from the axioms every statement you
obtain you call ethereum
and you kind of add it to the collection
of true statements
and then the question is how far can you
go how many statements can you prove
this way
of course you want it to be the system
to be non-trivial in the sense that you
don't prove everything
because if you prove everything it would
mean that it's self-contradictory that
you'd prove a statement a and it's
negation so that's kind of useless
it has to be discriminating enough
so that it doesn't doesn't prove
contradictory statements so that there
is already a question of that
mathematical consistency it has to be
consistent in the sense that
it is not self-contradictory
and then the idea that was basically
prevalent in the world of mathematics by
the beginning of the 20th century was
that in principle all of mathematics
could be derived this way we just have
to find the correct system of axioms
and then everything you ever need
would be
um
could be produced by this
procedure which is really algorithmic
procedure which which actually could be
run on a computer
now think about it what is special about
this process
in this process you are just
manipulating
symbols basically you're going from one
statement to another without really
understanding the meaning of it so it's
an ideal playground for a computer
program
it's a purely syntactic process where
there are some rules some rigid rules
of passing from one statement to the
next
most mathematician mathematicians
believed that this way you can produce
all true statements and if this were
true it would give a lot of credibility
to the thesis that everything in life is
computational
or life is computation because then at
least mathematics is computational
because then it can be programmed
and the computer after sufficient time
depending on on its capacity would
produce every true statement
so guildo's first incompetence theorem
says that that's not the case
and it's not just says it but it proves
it at you know the highest level of
rigor that is available in math Max that
is to say within another formal system
that he was operating in
so more precisely
what he proved was that if you have a
sufficiently sophisticated formal system
that is to say that you can talk about
numbers whole numbers in it that you
have whole numbers one two three four
you you have you can you have formalized
the procedure the operation of
additional multiplication
within the system
if it is consistent that is to say if
it's not complete completely useless
then there will be a true statement in
it which cannot be derived by this
linear syntactic process of proving
theorems from axioms
it's really incredible so this was a
revolution 1931 a revolution in logic
Revolution mathematics we're still
feeling the Tremors of
of this discovery in a similar time
the uh the computer is being born the
actual engineering of the computational
system is being born right which is a
electronic Turing was Turing was
um Alan Turing who was considered as the
father of modern Computing right so he
actually did something very similar so
he had a sculpting problem
he proved that halting problem cannot be
solved algorithmically that you cannot
out of all computer programs roughly
speaking you could not you could not you
cannot have an algorithm of choosing out
of all can be possible computer programs
which ones are meaningful which ones
will not which ones will hold very
depressing results all across the table
or on the contrary life affirming
that's on your point of view because
everything is full of paradoxes so that
means so you're right it's depressing if
we are sold on a certain idea from the
outset and then suddenly this doesn't
pan out
but okay so which my editored what if
what if he proved that actually
you know everything can be proved so
then what what is left to do if you're a
mathematician so that would be
depressing to me
and here there is an opportunity to do
something new to do to discover
something new which may be computer will
not be able to again with a caveat
according to our current understanding
maybe some new technology some new ideas
will be brought into the subject
and the meaning of the word computation
like now we think of condition a
particular framework tuning machines or
church thesis and stuff like that but
what if in the future another genius
like on Turing will come and propose
something else the theory will evolve
the way you know we went from Newton's
gravity to Einstein's gravity maybe in
the framework of that concept some other
things will become possible
you know so
um it's not
to me it's kind of like
not so much about
deciding once and for all how it is or
how it should be but kind of like
accepting it as an open-ended process I
think that's much more valuable in some
sense than deciding things one way or
another you know I wonder
I don't know if you think or know much
about cellular automata and the idea of
emergence
I I often return to Game of Life yeah
and just look at the thing amazing right
and wonder the kind of things they can
do with such a small
um you know tools yeah for simple rules
a distributed system can create complex
Behavior
and it makes you wonder that maybe the
thing we'll call computation
is simple at the base layer but when you
start looking at greater and greater
layers of abstraction you zoom out with
blurry vision maybe after a few drinks
you start to see some uh something
that's much much more complicated and
interesting and beautiful than the
original rules
that are scientific intuition says
cannot possibly produce complexity and
Beauty I don't know I don't know if
anyone has a good answer a good model of
why
stuff emerges
why complexity emerges from a lot of
simple things
it's a why question I suppose not a but
every why question will eventually have
a a rigorous answer not necessarily we
could have an approximate answer
which still eludes something like
quantum mechanics 99 maybe we'll be able
to describe it
was 99 certainty or 99 accuracy yeah and
then maybe you know
in in 100 years or you know next year
somebody will come up with a different
point of view which suddenly will change
our perspective
you know to this point I want to say
also you know one thing that I find
fascinating speaking of paradoxes and so
on
do you remember how everybody was
freaking out about this blue dress
and the blue was it blue or was it black
yeah it was the yellow I think what
yellow or and white or black and blue it
almost broke Twitter you know I remember
that yeah that night
so there are many examples like that
where you can perceive things
differently and there is no way of
saying which is correct which is not for
instance
uh you got this the bus the Rubens bars
you know where you have from one
perspective it's of us from another
perspective it's two faces
then there is this Duck Rabbit picture
where you can Google it if somebody
doesn't know they can Google it and find
it it's very easy actually Ludwig
wittenstein devoted several Pages doc
rabbit in his book
and so on there are many others there
are like the squares where you can
square you can see the from different
perspective this way that way and so on
so
when we talk about neural networks
we're talking about training
data and stuff and so that you have some
pictures for example that you feed to
your program
and you try to find the most optimal
neural network which would be able to
decide which one is it so the dog or cat
or whatever but sometimes it doesn't
have a definite answer
so what do you do then so do actually
it's a question I actually don't know
has modern AI even come to appreciate
this question that actually sometimes
you can have a picture on which you
cannot say what it is in it from one
perspective it's a rabbit from an
obsessed with is a duck how are you
supposed to train if you have a neural
network which is supposed to
discriminate between distinguish between
ducks and rabbits how is it going to
process this you see well so the the
trivial trick it does is to say there's
a this x probability that it's a duck
and this probability that it's a rabbit
but that's a good approach but also I
would say there's no like given
percentages for instance actually at
some point I was really curious about it
and I looked
and for some of for each picture of this
nature and there are a bunch of them you
can easily find online
my mind immediately interprets it in a
particular way but because I know that
other people have could see it
differently I would then strain my mind
and strain my eyes and stare at it and
try to see it in a different way and
sometimes I could see it right away and
then I could go back and forth between
the two and sometimes it could it took
me a while for some pictures
so in that sense even if this
probabilities exist they are subjective
some people immediately see it this way
some people may see that way and I think
that nobody knows not psychologists not
neuroscientists not philosophers what to
make of it
the best answer the best of course as a
scientific mind I will I'm even though I
say no don't look for interpretation
leave some place for mysticism or
mystery right I say that but of course I
want a theory I want an explanation
so the best explanation I find is from
Niels Bohr's complementarity principle
so it is like particle and wave
that there are different ways to look at
it and when you look at it in a
particular way another side will be
obscured think about it like the other
side of the moon you know so like we are
observing the Moon from one side and
then we don't see the other side there
is a complementary perspective where we
see the other side but not the side we
normally see but the Moon is the same
still there it's our limitations of
being able to grasp the whole that's
complementarity and we know that from
quantum mechanics that our physical
reality is like that
rather than being certain rather than
being one way or another
we should just as a small aside
in terms of neural networks mentioned
that
at the end of the day there's humans is
built on top of humans
or with chat GPT that is using
reinforcement learning by human feedback
we're actually using a set of humans
to teach the networks yeah and that's
the thing that people don't often talk
about because
or I I sometimes think about that
those humans all have a life story each
human the annotated data that fed data
to the network or did the rlhf yeah uh
that they have a life story they grew up
they have biases and biases are some
things that they like there's some
things they don't like which can kind of
appear under the Raider screen they may
not be aware that they are exercising
those biases that's the point what you
brought up is a very important issue
here not so it might issue but it's not
a bug it's a it's a feature in my
opinion that
implicit in the discussion of the
question
is thinking computational and so on is
the idea that our conscious awareness
covers everything within our psyche and
we we just know that that's not the case
we have all of us have observed uh other
people who have had sort of destructive
Tendencies so obviously they did things
distracting for themselves and many of
us have observed ourselves to doing that
as part of human nature right so and
there is great research in analytic
psychology and you know in the past
hundred years uh strongly suggesting if
not proving the existence of what Carl
Jung called the unconscious personal
unconscious and also Collective
unconscious that's a kind of Circle of
ideas which are under the radar screen
which lead us to some strong emotions
and Inspire us to act in certain ways
even if we cannot really understand
so if we accept that then it the
preposition that somehow everything can
still be covered by our actions which
are totally
kind of neutral and totally like
righteous and totally
um conscious that it becomes really
tenuous